what's that gonna do with me I'm asking
if you miss me but I'm not around
bro
[Music]
let's see when I'm not around
guys
as you already know we hit straight from
the source we go straight in with a
banger and the question of the week was
what's the secret that the group chat
doesn't even know about oh my gosh
that's Saucy I'm trying to think is
there any secrets that you man don't
know about
I don't think they're really
no there isn't see your boyfriend yeah
there actually isn't REM definitely has
bear he never contributes to the group
chat what's he on about
Rebel give a Prius 10 minutes later
after the dust set yeah bro
thanks
that's jokes all right back to him
what's the secret that the group chat
doesn't even know about as per usual
guys responses always juicy
I've got a crippling escort and campsite
addiction I'm currently in recovery
crippling escorts addiction bro I'm
currently in recrippling is the word I
got me
I can't afford this lifestyle I can't
keep this up man said I don't have money
to pay rent because I'm paying it on X
Nani
wow okay how do you fall into that bro
how do you actually fall into that
that's a that's a dark cycle yeah to be
fat to be fair we were on a uh I'm not
gonna name names not name a shame we
were on a stag you a few years ago right
okay and um remember this he was there
you were there but you weren't there
yeah yeah we saw you that might be
weren't in this room and we went into
one strip club okay and she do want to
Stack do yeah went in there fam
ten of us went in nine of us came out
long story sure
nine of us came out one brother did not
leave until they closed we went in there
like 9 00 p.m he didn't leave he was on
it on his ones bro no on his ones he did
not leave that establishment until they
asked him politely to get out
wow the sun was up it was baby blue baby
yeah it was I think it was wow
next day he had zero regrets
he was happy bro oh my that's crippling
crippling addiction oh say I've seen it
firsthand say less yeah bro oh you would
have had to drag me out if I was that my
man yeah get me out get me out of here
because I can't keep doing this because
I wouldn't know how to face you man the
next day at lunch and be just be all
smiles oh he was always because
I can't be asked for the questions you
might already know this is crippling for
me I was I was splurging all that yeah
yeah yeah yeah so I don't have time for
the questions bro you ready you saw it
what more jeans are you literally he
should have dragged me out I couldn't
believe it you should have dragged me
out he was happy to stay that's insane
yeah bro bro I've never seen anything
like it nah yeah so I can see where this
is and there's this guy's actually
getting Tom yes facts this guy's
actually gay he's Tom Roman money away
yeah wow wow right next I caught my ex
cheating by planting a recording device
he was with prostitutes
oh dear
I'm seeing a trend
turns out prosies are not included in
the group chat
jokes
I gave two of their siblings gonorrhea
their siblings
oh my god wow what violator
do you know what the gender of this
person is I can't remember wow
I can't remember
just waited me
my last breakup broke me
[Music]
[Laughter]
there's certain heartaches I've felt
where I don't feel confident telling a
group of people are fat it's just I need
to tell you and only you before I can
Broach this to anyone else because you
need to you need to you
use Tessa Waters exactly wow you saw
what I was like oh I did first half yeah
that could have never made it that
couldn't have made public domain
you saw it foreign
I'm not going to say his name but I
remember I remember one of our boys
right yeah yeah I already know who it is
one of our boys right
I think he was on holiday he must have
been on no I think he was in Italy or
something for a wedding
I think it was a Grieves when I wanted a
friend of the group and he was drinking
that night and he he bust upon his story
no regrets on his story no regrets funny
story I honestly knew what the context
was the next morning man wrote mad
regrets on Easter wait he spot regrets
wrong he didn't really regret oh bruh
twist up I remember do you remember the
photo he put in the chat of him slumped
on the toilet do you remember yeah I do
remember oh this is Jesus Christ Jesus
been through it it was not you by the
way Rose I know it was
but yeah oh that killed me killed me
all right back to it what's the secret
that a group chat doesn't even know
about
I sent him so much money and I don't
even come when we have sex
of course you don't you can't let the
group chat know that you can never let
the group chat know that I Stace and I
love him I I send him bags on bags
she's so white and he's so black do you
know how mad that is
actually know who Matt her mother is do
you know the funniest thing about that
oh it was a black girl I remember
[Music]
because I remember it's not even easily
manipulated
she knows exactly what she's doing not
even what are you trying to say in these
streets
hilarious you're too funny brother
episode
I've got that too late that was too
funny oh God
do you know why that I was saying it bro
because growing up yeah I think I told
you before
um
I grew up in an area where everyone goes
pen
okay context
where everyone it's just a right passage
to go pen
so many people I grew up with went pen
yeah yeah and as soon as they go out the
first time obviously all the guys are
black the first time you see them out of
jail is in the passenger side of some
white girl's car it's always like a
Corsa or a sea or something like that do
you write it's always always so when I
heard that I thought yeah we're
following Trends yeah yeah Dynamics say
less
not even easily
born with essentially that's hilarious
pregnancy dot dot dot with someone in
the group chat's man no no no no no no
no no no
with someone in a group female group
chats Have No Boundaries they do not
it's a it's a show for them
it's all for show there's no death
wow that's mental that's so juicy a
factual you don't understand Factory how
I would love to hear that third person
all right from my girl to tell me
babe babe babe this can't make the group
chat but listen to me oh my God
oh that's a that's a story that's a
story
I have a toe fetish from time to time I
would put peanut butter on my own feet
and lick them myself okay that's
that needs recovery
lick them myself
brother that's a that's not a toe face
that's yeah yeah that's when you
fetishize about site you don't think
about on you yeah I have them too yeah
so yeah wow yeah that's you need surgery
or something yes you can do some
my best friend's husband tried to kiss
me
scary
I couldn't be confronted with that
James I couldn't be confronted with that
yeah I couldn't there's no way you would
come to me be like bro
I love you no no no no no no no Matt you
would say this man
don't get vet because it's not my fault
that's exactly what I'm saying oh grab
your hoodie man to man don't get vexed
but it's not my fault don't [__]
react so that's gonna say don't you
[__] react over because I know what
you're like that's exactly what you said
I'll give you all the premise in the
world bro
shop and hear me bro
your wife tried to lips me Josh moved in
she moved in that year wasn't my 10.
she moved in I'm like what
bro I would I wouldn't know how to react
to her I wouldn't know how to tell you I
know you wouldn't but that that scenario
is utility oh 100. I'm like fine
whatever you do don't do it that's the
first one
wherever you do just don't do it don't
do it to me don't do it to her don't do
us in the situation when I leave do what
you need to do
I love you and I love her she's
wonderful
the Sherry was flowing oh the Sherry
Sherry was flowing and I don't know what
happened I don't know if she mistook us
or anything your home girl tried to lips
man
she mistook us a sign she tried to lips
ah that will break me bro oh that would
break me
wow you know why I know I couldn't tell
you because your reaction would break me
because you would
underreact so much in that moment
because you're a man
and I just want to say this you're a
[__] man don't let anyone tell you
different I know they're charity but I
don't want you to lose it
my boy is a real mad in that moment you
would hold it so tight in your chest and
you'll be like bro thank you for telling
me probably and you'll walk into the
kitchen and my knees were buckled
because I
I couldn't oh that would kill him right
because yeah you're right I'm not one to
make a scene you're not gonna make a
scene and I would make a scene so much
but by the time you're gone I'd be calm
oh days anyway what's the secret that
the group chat doesn't even know about
it
right now
look at him right sorry carry on I
banged one of my friend's wife the day
before the wedding and I still went to
the wedding of course you did
treacherous treacherous wow a man has a
Mane and aside in our group chat when
the main complains the side is the first
to give advice hashtag clueless made
wow
and you're just a third party witnessing
all this happen so this is just guys and
girls in here this is a free-for-all
group chat I've never heard of such yeah
I've never even heard of such
free-for-all groups I did yeah
clueless clueless clueless Mane
wow
I had sex with my ex and I don't know
whether I came or peed long story short
he changed his mattress
yeah his whole mattress yeah he would
have been guessed either way long she
definitely peed though 100
me and my wife were swingers
um me and my wife were in swingers
websites and we've had three Sims and
foursomes
damn I wouldn't put that in the group
chat either neither would I I actually
wouldn't I would I couldn't
because we see each other imagine being
so into stuff but I just can't even tell
you but I'm just so embarrassed to tell
you
foursomes
is it is it embarrassment or is it
fear of what that person will think of
you isn't that the definition of
embarrassment yeah but like
it's that's Peak that is very it is
because we're family yeah and I'm pretty
sure I could sell you on it I'm not
gonna lie to you I got for sure I can
sell you on it
bro I went to one thing that's not even
stop that's our [__] stop right now I
went to one party yesterday in it me and
the missus
what's it saying I know yeah I'd hide my
face
those things in there oh that's I swear
things
like I know that's what I'm like I'm not
glad it's a sex place though
and then I'll get you sold on it and I'm
like cool full disclosure it wasn't a
sex part it was a swingers party
full disclosure it wasn't things it was
Couples
oh disclosure it was on my head yeah
yeah
I hosted
but the rest is true come through here
come through
hilarious another one on Wednesday you
have to come
I FaceTime a guy to watch him have sex
with another woman
what kind of Kink slash thing is that
she faced time to do to watch him bang
another chick that's her that's her
thing that's a thing and she can't tell
a song fair play
past raunch
that's giving uh do you remember what
was it what's that film 365 days do you
remember that film oh the the foreign
thing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the man
had her up in a jail cell an embroidered
a thing to slap him off yeah yeah and
she couldn't stand to watch yeah yeah
she was shivering and salivating and
everything got top in the airplane as
well yeah he did where he just robbed
the faceland outside he's uh annoying
boy you're a naughty boy I could never
Pat on top of the plane like that I'm
The Man by the way if if I come back
from behind the curtain yeah just carry
on the meeting because I'm On Top from
the air hostess yeah you're a guy
that's it bro
stayed celibate for a man inside only
for him to be released and ghost be
oh I can't tell us all God yeah of
course you can't tell
that I'm still getting head from the
problematic redhead that has plagued our
friendship group
that's no that's
that's
just slop just slop from the problematic
redhead that plagued our friendship
group
it must have been some head yeah yeah
yeah yeah of course a man doesn't even
bang her Jessica's head that's delicious
bro that's so toxic it's delicious wow
yeah [__] wow oh my goodness
they think I'm in the gym but I sat at
home and cried over the boy they told me
not to get involved with
oh God
[Laughter]
uh uh human beings are so stupid all of
us bro we are we just all are as a race
we are yeah we are how we've made it
this far I don't know one of their
husbands stays begged in my DMs oh okay
that's dark I've had sex with loads of
women but that quarter body sex toy is
top 10.
is that just fighting Fighters belly
button yeah just titty an ass
wow top ten top 10 he said
Matt said his top ten The Core Body
wow Jesus facts all right Dharma
Christ that's weird that's why yeah yeah
man doesn't want to see faces yeah yeah
that's top ten top top ten torso
that doesn't make sense brother it
doesn't
that's disgraceful he just wants full
control and he doesn't want anyone to
speak back to him that's all he wants
that's all he wants bro
a man's slamming it talking the money oh
yeah saying everything
to say something back oh God
oh Jesus that's yeah that's a lot man
that is a lot I used to feed pork to my
Muslim ex without him knowing after we
had an argument
I'm glad it's not in the group chat
because you'd be like yeah yeah what'd
you call it
exiled yeah you'll be exiled immediately
my boy my boy got chlamydia from his
wife she got it from me I got it from
his sister no
yes bro yes what a whirlwind what a
whirlwind it's a whirlwind
stays disrespecting his boy hang on
let me read it again he banged his
sister and then his wife bro my boy got
chlamydia from his wife she got it from
me I got it from his sister
hmm
that's treacherous wow that could
obviously never make the group we're not
boys I like these alarm boys or girls
yeah true dated my ugly but sweet
co-worker when he told everyone about us
I denied everything
damn Pete damn yeah those your standards
will slip in the office boy
they will slip
none of them will probably be my
bridesmaids
none of them yeah
none of them bro
when it comes to
when it comes to women's weddings if you
don't meet the criteria I don't care how
long you've known me facts yeah I don't
care if you delivered my firstborn
lose weight or you won't be in the
lineup
facts they don't give a [__] they don't
give a flying apart they don't care bro
that's hilarious that's hilarious hmm
I have a club across town to go oh sorry
I have a club across town to go to alone
to be a hoe in peace they judge me if
they saw me
Just Dance and does it up
fair play
fair play I just want to be a hoe in
peace I don't want judgment on pipe are
they really your friends then are you
really friends with them
not really actually yeah yeah yeah
because if you find them yeah you man
could never get in my way if I'm just
trying to help it up
I shouldn't have to cross town exactly
to do what I want to do exactly
just accept me for who I am exactly yeah
yeah yeah facts I've got a few more
my ex called me a spineless man
I also couldn't tell you about that
oh I'm not saying to solve that bro I'm
not telling the soul and I'll deny it if
she says it yeah you're a spineless man
is also a form of gang and like it's
full of bullies even though it is all
confidence it's also just bullies and I
couldn't go there and be like my girl
just called me spineless
but I found something like that why did
she call you why did you please find
this because
I don't know I just I don't like to make
her mad
I don't like to make a mess I don't make
like to make a cross cross you're a yes
man that's how it starts
because why'd she call you spineless
because
some guy cut in front of me at the
petrol station
and then like gave me the finger and I
didn't I didn't say anything I said
nothing I just didn't want that smoke
spineless yeah
some guy like smacked her ass in front
of me and I I like I did give him like a
nod right hey you ever do that again hey
that look yeah yeah yeah yeah but she
said I was spinous because I didn't
protect her
yeah yeah the one should swallow me
Whole Life yeah yeah
I caught my man sorry
I caught my man deep throat in my
friend's dad I still go to therapy till
this day
last but not least come on
I was sleeping with my best friend's
wife for a year their new baby has my
eyes
that would terrify me
wouldn't it just that would I'm moving
to Argentina wouldn't it you would
survive in Argentina by the way why
spin-off random it's a crime crime
not even about crying we're saying gay
brothers let me speak bro
let me speak walk on there is not one
ounce of color in Argentina oh
during the World Cup yeah yeah
pure whites bro like okay in South
America there's always a mix of like
race and blah blah Argentina yeah they
stay clean they bro clean's the one
there's nothing but whites but does that
doesn't make sense bro it's too hot for
that I've never understood hot countries
that are racist you know what I mean
it doesn't make sense I'm not I didn't
see a speck of color
Ed there girls are banging as well bro
you wouldn't survive it there they would
look at you like you're a museum oh
an antique wow yeah but that was my last
one okay fair enough wow okay guys
welcome back happy Monday
um as always guys if you enjoy the show
that much prove it in fact head on over
to patreon.com forward slash shits and
gigs right now and donate something
don't even donate like
spend spend three pounds of your
hard-earned money
once a month that's all we asked three
pound of your hard-earned cash spend it
on us and enjoy an extra episode of our
content every single Thursday and enjoy
our entire catalog
three years plus over on patreon
and along with all the other benefits
okay you get indoctrinated into the
official cult baby crew where you can
jump on our Discord Channel have a chin
rack have a laugh enjoy everything that
we have on over there so that's
patreon.com it's going to cost you an
easy three pound a month for measly 10p
a day run the pizza sng right now guys
if you haven't got your tickets already
please please guys The Log Cabin tour is
now on sale where one is flying off the
shelf bro leave London Manchester
Birmingham Bristol
we're gonna come and see you so come and
see us okay right guys uh Link's in the
description grab your tickets ASAP
please they are flying off the shelves
and thank you to everyone that's already
uh booked and busy to come and see us
and guys last but not least if you are
watching us on YouTube please subscribe
to the channel it would mean the world
to us this channel is growing incredibly
fast and we cannot believe what our
lives currently look like and also on
top of that guys if you are listening on
all any of the podcast apps please leave
us a nice review
um literally five stars is preferable
but whatever you got to do say we adjust
come on man uh and without any further
Ado I'm going to hand you over to my
comrade Fire Lord flakes
Big Daddy flag is going to hit us with a
fun fact okay let's do it it's not
really fun but it's a fact oh God in
2010 Gareth Williams a British MI6 spy
was found dead at his flap with his um
decomposing body in a bathtub padlocked
inside the bag police wrote it the death
as an accident
um concluding he died by get getting
into the back hit on his own and
accidentally locking himself inside huh
yes spreader yes let me read more
context it's mad so they're saying um
the police visited his home in Monday
the 21st 2010 for a welfare check after
the colleagues noted that he um lacked
contact for several days his naked
decomposing remains were found in a buff
and I'm of the main bedroom ensuite
um inside of a red bag with the padlock
from the outside with the key is still
inside the bag the police at gate entry
in the top floor of the flat around 6
40. his family alleged that crucial DNA
was interfered with and the fact that
the fingerprints left at the scene were
wiped off as part of it as a cover-up
inconclusive fragments of DNA components
from the at least two other contributors
were found on the bag
obviously as I said before he was MI6 as
well so he's it's all nuts it's all a
conspiracy so he's an MI6 agent yeah X
MI6 MI6 agent who just happened to put
himself inside a bag
and and keep the key in there keep the
key in the back but pan lock it from the
outside how first and foremost and his
body was just rotting away there's a
government level cover-up it's a cover
sounds like we've got a whistleblower on
our hands that it happened Saturn
happens damn Scotland yards um inquiry
also found no evidence of um William's
finger on the padlock
um of the bag or on the rim of the bath
which the corridor said supported her
assertation of the third party
involvement of the death
and the police deputy said that it was
theoretically possible for Williams to
lower himself into the bag without
touching the rims of the bath a key to
the padlock was inside the bag
underneath his body interesting but yeah
long story short these men are saying it
was an accident that he his body was
inside a bag
padlock was outside and the key was in
on his board basically on his person
and we've got two separate two strands
of DNA yeah that's been just wiped off
they said it's not worth talking about
yeah it's just oh brother yeah yeah this
was in 2010. we need to know what you
worked on yeah he we do need what was
his last case what was his last let me
let me start this they're not going to
show his last case but he must have been
doing something very very very sus yeah
bro he uncovered something in there he
did these men are working for Hydra
Hydra these men are working for Hydra
Hydra you know men went Marvel with it
that's hilarious wow that's so
fascinating bro stuff like that is um
when you when you see stuff like that
movies you're like yeah but surely
someone's gonna figure it out do you
know I mean like surely something you
see that that's mad bro that was 13
years ago we didn't I didn't have heard
about it till now I never knew this
existed because they covered it up they
kept it and probably the people that are
involved they're exempt now speaking of
them to exonerated or something all
right gentlemen listen to me for a quick
second please it's a very very important
Valentine's Day is Round the Corner can
we be bothered to get flowers no can we
be bothered to go out no so what do we
want to do we want to clap some cheeks
so let's make it the best clap cheek
session we can with our trusted sponsor
for today which is man escaped guys you
need to shave your balls and get it in
order okay let's make Valentine's Day
special let's make it important and
let's get away with murder okay
so guy
um get lucky this Valentine's Day and
all you need to do is join the seven
million men worldwide 14 billion balls
[Laughter]
give or take
um worldwide to trust masket along with
your cult that is over here who are
leaders in below the waist grooming and
all you need to do is head on over to
manscape.com and use the code sng you
already know Sierra November Golf and
that's going to give you 20 off and free
shipping right let's get back to the
episode thank you very much
um speaking of cover-ups oh
there's a documentary I need to see okay
um I can't remember what it's called
that's good I will figure it out all
right it's called Vatican girl The
Disappearance of Emmanuela Orlando I've
seen I think I've seen it show me show
me the thingy
I think I've seen the trailer maybe it's
not that new is it oh it says 2022 on
here
um maybe it's early 22.
October 22 too it's complete it's not
it's not what I've seen that all right
but yeah
um so so how much do you know about
vacancy not much I know it's his own
it's like a sovereign
[Applause]
Vatican City is his own country he's got
his own rules and it has like his own
police force and everything okay and
this documentary is about
um a girl who went missing what's your
reporter or something no she's a little
girl oh [__] yeah you're right yeah yeah
so basically um
apparently I've heard Whispers so you
know what was that film that we watched
about the
um
the like child molesting priests
cover-up thing
I had um the film yeah as a film with um
oh
um
um I know exactly yeah exactly because
the paper in Boston I can see I can see
it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so yeah
that so
um apparently there's like there's been
stuff about like how the
um
the church will move all these priests
that they're moving around a lot of them
they'll move into the vacancy okay by
the way huh dark Waters dark Waters bro
um
they're moving into Vatican City they
can't be touched so apparently Vegas is
just Filipinos
spare pedos oh my god do it up Church
um and there's a story about this little
girl who went missing in the Vatican
City and
hop skip jump I need to watch it because
their parents just cover-up thing
apparently there's Clues a guanine is
documentary okay have to watch it
because that's that's my kind of sauce
you're talking about this yeah yeah I
love [__] like that yeah when Saturn's
doesn't doesn't taste right yeah I want
to sink my teeth into it I need to find
the truth
yeah we deserve to know yeah yeah yeah
yeah so yeah I'm gonna look out for that
yeah yeah yeah when we look out for that
that Vatican girl thing it sounds um it
sounds decent I'm gonna try and watch
that cool
um but speaking of we've got our
um our quick Last of Us catch up oh yeah
three episode three yeah I'll let you go
first Peng
um
this could be a hot take I think it's
the best episode yet so they've said oh
is that what the crit is gonna say yeah
I think so I think like they gave it
like 9.6 or something like that I
thought it was truly
beautiful it was I'll leave it all right
you're gonna disagree but it is all
right cool so let me promise this in my
personal opinion I usually hate side
quests I don't like distracting from the
main like I don't like Filler episodes
let's keep on track what we're doing
this one spun me in a way that like I
didn't know what was going on for so
long yeah and then once I figured it out
um because I'm not smart enough I didn't
even clock the names at first
um so yeah once we get onto this side
questing
I don't know they just I think the
reason I liked it so much is because
like I said I don't like Filler episodes
and they had me locked in for every
every second of this episode
um
and it gave me Brokeback Mountain
I see that yeah there was just
um
and I like that when uh so the the main
guy what's his name again yeah Bill he's
a comedy actor right yeah he's in um in
parks and rec Clark's a wreck yeah
um Ron Swanson Ron Swanson from box and
Rec
um I like when comedy actors can do
serious roles
um and I think he did it well and um
and it was just flagrantly gay and it
was lovely they portrayed it very well
they did they did good boy and um there
was little funny quips in there and it
was just yeah bro it was just a
fulfilling relationship and someone said
this to me about it the other day that I
actually really agree with it's nice in
these like kind of like zombie style
shows and stuff like that are like
post-apocalyptic it's nice to see a
situation where someone dies of old age
as opposed to getting eaten by zombie or
something like that like you I didn't
expect it to end that way yeah and this
whole Romeo and Juliet thing they did at
the end yeah I was like oh okay it was a
heart wrencher that was a wholesome
wholesome wholesome episode I think they
did for what it was I just think they
did it incredibly well and it's lucky
for them to keep me locked in for that
long so my don't get me wrong I still
thought it was a heartfelt episode but
there were times where like there were
some great moments like for example when
um Frank who owns the house bill bill so
when Frank came obviously found him in a
home
Etc and when it's like just give me five
minutes I'm taking a shower just give me
five more minutes it's been years and
it's like blah blah then he sat down to
have the the rabbit as soon as he took
the first pipe I was like oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah spin fast forward to the
end when he took the last week of wine
with the thing in again he was like I've
just felt like that that was beautiful
in the sense that they threw it full
circle yeah yeah
why say I didn't like
I was a little bit bored I'm not gonna
lie okay yeah yeah and also I didn't
watch on Monday when it came I think I
watched it on I watched on Wednesday and
I'd already seen that
um on social studies it dubbed One of
the most heart-wretched episodes going
oh so you had my premise was already
like oh I don't know what to expect but
I'm expecting something yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so that for me I feel like if
I hadn't seen that it could have been a
bit better okay yeah I didn't see
anything that [__] me off yeah I just
saw that and then when I watched I was
like it was don't get me wrong
the way the thing was completely
portrayed amazing yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah for them to have survived that long
as well amazing so yeah it was it was a
really good episode I did like the
Throwbacks I did like obviously when
they brought Joel in um is it Tess yeah
yeah that was cool from from way back
when yeah yeah and then at the end when
he was right in the when she read out
the I said look after 10. she couldn't
even read that Ellie couldn't find it
she said look after and she was up
first of all take that face off because
this is real situation yeah yeah I don't
want to be like
she's dead
stop playing that yeah yeah that's the
love of my life I've uh what I've been
through bro I'm Joel what I've been
through I don't need that face right
yeah yeah yeah yeah you need that face
right it's so punchable yeah yeah it's a
bag yeah yeah yeah yeah such a punchable
face yeah like the tawnies that have a
relationship are dead upstairs the love
of my life is dead and you're reading up
and think of being like and it's all
your fault facts so don't give me that
um yeah yeah but it was it was a really
really good episode I wasn't expecting
the whole thing to be based around these
two I just said like a side quest type
of thing but I did like how they
obviously put Joel and um test into it
again Joel and Ellis or Ellie rather at
the end fair play it was cool do you
know what I liked about it as well is
that this is hasn't really nothing to do
with the episode really but it's like
games because obviously I I'm starting
even though I've never played the game
I'm trying to imagine this in game
format and like I forgot that episode
didn't forget was the game yeah bro and
I can imagine like the fan service if
you have played the game I can imagine
like you've got this in my head I'm
making this up obviously I imagine
you've got this like uh gay survivalist
couple that have their own little
village within like outside the QC and
all this stuff and like maybe you you
get like tidbits of their life and maybe
you don't but like to have give them
like a whole episode yeah I bet it was
like I can imagine it was good fan
service for people of the game Who not
understand who these characters are to
get like a full episode dedicated to
them yeah I can imagine that'd be really
really fulfilling I hear that completely
yeah yeah I reckon from that perspective
I hear that I reckon it would have been
ping
um and uh what was the other thing also
no one could tell me
um Frank isn't the top
no one can ever tell me Frank isn't a
little slag yeah he's a jealous a man
said I don't free up pom for dinners for
dinner so I'm gonna be here I'm gonna be
here for a few days okay it must start
on top is it okay he stroked his hair I
said I'm gonna be here for a few days I
don't care who you are
I don't care how horny I am yeah yeah
don't stop making demands in my yard bro
because you've taken a young shower I
had some Munch too too Sharon I cooked
you dinner you're telling me you're
gonna be here for a few days no no no no
no no no no no no no no
[__] get your ass off me bro this is a
we're in an apocalypse you're not making
rules here bro you can't make rules yeah
yeah yeah
um but yeah he was too horny man said
yeah yeah and it had physical class for
four years yeah that's four years that's
a lot that's a lot and he's never banged
a guy yeah yeah yeah he said have you
done it before he said no he said he
banged a girl back a day and it was
weird
okay guys I've slept with girls first
I remember when I used to do the like uh
Butler's in the buff bro
every time I'd meet a gay guy they'd
always tell me they lost their virginity
to a girl
I mean
I'm not saying it doesn't surprise me at
the same time it doesn't surprise me it
doesn't really I guess I guess it
doesn't surprise me but at the time I
remember thinking damn for all of you
that doesn't sound fun at all it really
does because imagine if it was the other
way around
not fun no it doesn't sound fun it
really doesn't sound fun it doesn't
sound fun whatsoever and that's my first
experience trying to discover your
sexuality at such a young age that's
tough yeah you're just literally you're
going for the norm which is heterosexual
and it's like what yeah what yeah it's
and you just don't you start you're just
like this is really not for me yeah it's
slippy and warm and like I don't know
smooshy this is best smush I just I just
don't think this is for yeah I want
Power
do you know what I mean yeah throw me do
something wrestle me cyan what's with
this smush oh man that's tough man yeah
yeah it doesn't surprise me that um most
men have lost their well most gay men
have lost opportunity to girls well I
don't know what the fact is what stats
are but it doesn't surprise me yeah
maybe I'm being a bit Brazen saying most
just the ones I've met which is not most
yeah I mean like six
um but yeah anyway yeah last of us I'm
enjoying it man I really am too I'm
looking forward to the next episode
um I'm excited they've already got um
they're already scheduled for season two
so yeah man nine and it's nine episodes
long so we'll see that's paying it also
must be like super
um gratifying to be like a writer or a
director or an actor on the show and
literally one episode in they're like
season two let's go yeah yeah that's
like oh my pen game is strong yeah my
game is strong clearly oh clearly season
two one episode in yeah so yeah yeah oh
that was banging as well Jesus that was
banging and I like that um these men
don't have like a scheduled amount of
time per episode because obviously the
first one was a long one it was like one
three five second one was just over an
hour they're moving like podcasts the
third one was like an hour and a half
it's done when it's done yeah it's done
we're done when we say cut yeah yeah
yeah I think it's gonna be an hour thing
yeah these are chapters we're talking
about yes exactly Don't Force us don't
pigeonhole us into this little 59 minute
thing yeah we're done when we're done I
love the book yeah I love that as well
so yeah up God damn it's good Christ
right you've got trash news for us right
I do fear got it wrong it's Spotlight
it's not that one maybe a spotlight yeah
so REM just corrected me off camera dark
Waters is still good though it is but
yeah spotlight's the one Jimmy we'll
talk about anyway
um this is a
I'm assuming a Facebook post and I read
the caption I'll show you the picture
afterwards yeah okay
I'm looking for the stupid guy who
painted this dog like a tiger
I ran two kilometers to save my life I
only stopped when He barked only then I
could tell it was a dog
Roy looks like a tiger
thinking grow up yeah I mean you're
picking right yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm
dying off if I saw that he ran 2K to
save his life it looks just like a tiger
damn it you would from I wear glasses as
well from a distance yeah that's that's
a tiger
that's terrifying that is absolutely
terrifying James I couldn't be in this
area if I if this happened how it makes
you when you find out as a dog how vexed
I would probably be as Vex is this one
yeah it's a fair enough Facebook post I
need to find this [__] that did
this why would you pay your dog to scare
the town yeah yeah suggest
[Laughter]
just going about his business yeah do
people just running and screaming he
probably thinks they're playing along
oh that's why he chasing for 2K oh my
goodness that's why he's chasing for two
kilometers he's a little game
that could never be me oh yeah
and the worst thing was is that they'd
have to hear from you man because the
fear of me seeing a tiger in a suburban
area I'll just die on the spot I know
exactly how cold my Chester had and I'll
just die
them Indian tigers you see remember that
I want to try to drape the guy off the
car so yeah I wouldn't wait around to
find out and they pick up pace bro so
yeah wow that's scary one [__] super
funny prank but what an [__] I'm just
not down for stuff like that that would
kill me James
that would kill none of you might could
ever do that to me that would kill me
as a little prank yeah it would kill me
as well of course bro I couldn't of
course I just couldn't bro Jesus
um I have a question for you please
question me
right so when you have
ideas or thoughts about what you're
going to talk to me about on the Pod do
you ever play in your head how the
conversation would go
God
the reason why I asked I'll give you
context okay
I never do this yeah yeah I never do
this yeah no it's his name without you I
never do this but I have to give someone
their props oh I never do this
I went to a spot with Toby last week we
were meant to go to once but I'm not
going to give them the shower because we
didn't go there but we went to another
spot called lit it's actually called lit
it's lit partner lit Grill and shisha
something like that first of all you're
spending a lot of time with Toby and I
feel left out
that's two weeks in a row now that
you've spoken stuff that you've been
doing with Toby a few weeks at a roll
brother you missed a week then whatever
I see you every week bro that's for work
you see me for money if
you ain't getting paid you wanna see me
every week
don't lie to me bro bro if we come on do
you miss me when I'm not around
[Music]
when is when you haven't spotted me but
when it's Wednesday and you're seeing me
tomorrow
do you think I can't wait to see James
or do you do you write as I say
recording day tomorrow it depends wait
wait let me ask
ing before I get back to this yeah let
me answer please clarify I would only
roll my eyes if I know I don't have
enough stuff for tomorrow's session
what's that gonna do with me I'm asking
if you miss me when I'm not around
bro
[Music]
let's see what I'm not around
oh all right snow Allegra [__] that's
jokes oh Jesus ah
um Karen what do you do with him
I can't even say his name what did you
do with him
right went
to a spot right yeah um and I had
arguably the best chicken wings I've
ever had shut your mouth that sounds
banging I've ever had bro I couldn't
believe what I was tasting okay break
everything down for me okay I'll be
talking
um
deep fried or coated
no no it wasn't deep fry it was coated
it was coated and glazed okay coated and
glazed bro what's up okay sorry okay
sorry I'm excited I am let me tell you I
love Wings bro
no one can somebody had the best wings
of their life
okay okay okay okay okay
so
you know me anytime I see something
barbecuey that's me yeah same with um
with the way the menu was up it just
said chicken wings and it had like the
different flavors underneath like they
had sweet chili some some some and
obviously barbecue was there for some
reason the sweet cheated one was first
and it was just calling my name
interesting
James so like bet and we shared
everything so I was like let's get a
portion of the sweet chili
but I saw Bob kid I can't even remember
what the barbecue one was that's how
uninterested I was when I saw the sweet
chili and I can't believe it because I
would always draw something always never
pick sweet chili brother
I pick sweet chili best decision I've
ever made swear
um I think we get like eight then
medium-sized wings
scalding hot oh that's why I like it I
like it yeah yeah that's the way daddy
likes it go on the flavor profile bro I
couldn't believe what I was eating I
ordered another
um I ordered another round of route I
ordered another pair of wings or a bunch
of wings for the table and I ordered
another one to take home
that's how much in love I was with dude
I couldn't believe it it's called what
lit something lit but
okay back to the question I asked you
yeah yeah context as to why I brought
this up yeah the reason why
um this came up in my mind was because
I was eating the
um the ones I took home probably like
the day after I'd reheated them for like
minute and a half Perfect by the way
perfect
one minute one end off 700 wattage
perfect wings
um I put I warmed it in the plastic
container and I just poured it into the
bowl so all the juices were just
floating perfect that they were the
viscosity yeah it was Elite yeah Elites
as I was back in these wings I was
thinking God damn they taste as good as
when I got them from the restaurant
yesterday when I was thinking to myself
I wonder if I was to have this
conversation or tell James about this
how this conversation would go and my
thought process was you would ask me oh
where is this at and I will tell you it
was a new cross and you're like where
the [__] is new cross that's exactly
what would happen where the [__] is new
cross I was like South London you would
kiss your teeth roll your eyes and say
you're never going to see me in South
London so [__] them wings and [__] you
that's exactly how the thought process
went
you say something like if unless we do
like a little link up or there's like
some client meeting yeah no you're gonna
catch me yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly how
much factually not and you know what's
funny as well is now I know you do miss
me so you could have just said you
didn't miss me
you could have just said that from the
start dang all right cool
back to the question I asked you
um bro that's funny it's funny you say
that because my initial my initial thing
is to say no I don't
but there I don't run through how I
think the conversation is going to go
but I definitely have certain things
where I'm like this is gonna bang like I
can't wait to talk about this because I
know what your reaction is going to be
and it's gonna make me laugh
um but that's the most I've never done
that but I've done I've I've done not
necessarily with the podcast but I've
done that with a million other things
and like I can speak for you there's
other times
where um people might say oh you should
talk about this on your podcast and I'll
be like fear doesn't play that [__]
fear just doesn't play
so I'm not gonna talk about it
that's hilarious so yeah there's a
bedtime
but yeah with myself yeah no
no no no no because the way that
conversation went in my head sweetened
me so you're making me want to go get
these Wings though
new cross
props where know how to make wings I
won't be surprised if you sell out next
week
um yeah this is going to affect me
because now we're not gonna be able to
get a table
um I'm going to want to go there it's
going to be busy bro
based on recommendation yeah yeah
effects
um okay though yeah oh goodness me
goodness
it's annoying because you're so I'm not
gonna go there you're never gonna go
there bro that's the thing you're never
gonna go there I'm so annoyed by that
because I'm thinking we don't even get
offers to go to South East yeah no we've
got no reason business down there we've
got no business down there bro south of
the wall ah bro
damn yeah okay I'm trying to think yeah
yeah you're trying to make plans today
we're trying to make plans how can I go
there it's not going to be a thing yeah
yeah yeah what's that what else is in
southeast
like any like anything that I would go
to uh you're better fastened over than
me bro I have no idea that doesn't
matter I have no way it's completely
pointless
um all right fair enough cool you've got
a oh right you're taking over today
you've got a scenario now I do have
scenario jeez this um I got sent a while
back maybe
a few weeks ago
but I didn't have a chance to talk about
you may have seen as well women asked
her child women asked her child's father
for three hundred dollars to bail her
current boyfriend out of jail have you
seen this
yes I haven't read it obviously but I
did I've seen it someone sent it to me
my baby mum called today and asked if I
could give her 300 to help her pay her
rent
see I don't live with her so I don't
usually do [__] like that for real for
real people 100 emoji as well
I told her let me think about it and I
would call her back
before I called her back her sister
called me and told me that my BM was
lying I know and do not give her the
money
she said the real reason my baby mum
wanted 300 was to get her new guy out of
jail so she could um be close to him for
his birthday oh my God
I thought to myself
ra but I did but I still decided to give
her the money anyway because I knew God
would bless me so I called my baby mum
to come get the money and just a few
hours later I get a call from the county
jail it was my baby mum crying screaming
and asking why I gave her counterfeit
money my response so you could be closer
to your new man for his birthday see I
caught a blessing because my baby mom
can't file her taxes while she's in jail
so she can't stop me from filing our
daughter this year for filing to get our
daughter this year
wow scenario bro that's a that's a
massive scenario I mean it's one of them
ones where it's like props to him but
also sounds severe
what you're talking about sounds very do
or die yeah yeah yeah yeah man said I'm
gonna fail to get our daughter like
what's all yeah like yeah
that's all that's very dark yeah and I
want to be like ah gang got gotcha but
I'm like Jesus yeah but why are you
asking me for money yeah don't ever I
need help with my rent can I please have
300 specifically these hundred dollars
uh you couldn't
you could I couldn't find out that's
what it's for and then I barely be like
bro bro she's lying to you bro she's
absolutely lying her man's in pen and
she wants to mouth she wants him out for
his birthday she wants to be close to
the man for his birthday that's why she
wants the free bills I'm not lying to
you brother don't give it to her don't
give it to her
and you're like I'm a good Christian I I
would give it to her regardless
ah man just give her where did he get
counterfeit bills from that's another
question for another yeah he sounds like
he just got out of jail himself thanks
bro facts bro oh there's something
new man drama is is too much bro
what would you do and where's he staying
by the way in my daughter's yard
when he gets out in pain where's he
staying oh the new man yeah Oh I thought
you meant the mate
that's what I'm saying bro in my door's
yard it's all nuts right brother no I
would have given account now
I would have given and give her that as
well you can cry in there with him you
can cry in there you were gonna bring a
convict to my daughter's house just so
you can spend time with him on his
birthday [__] his birth date
yeah damn to stop committing crimes
facts wow these are people's lives
you're playing with facts
Jesus but yeah I had to read that one
out that's insane I had to read that one
out okay say less right um we've got a
couple tweets to finish we've got just a
couple tweets and then we'll wrap this
baby up my wife slapped the [__] out of
me last night because I was smiling in
my sleep
what slap the [__] out of me because I
was smiling in my sleep brother
bro oh I know bear women that would do
that as well no justice no peace
what are you smiling at who's got you so
happy in there
brav
no justice no Beast bro
wow oh fam this one's sweetened me this
one actually sweeted me
um I saw some story actually don't cheat
then come home acting sleepy get the
[__] up you've got another [__] to eat
laughs
wow bum
I don't know if I'll be aroused or mad
all right same here
get the [__] up you got another [__]
[__] to eat you think you can just
gallivant and cheat and go sleep
you've got a woman here that one
satisfying tired get up
look at that babes babe please come on
man that she took it
it took it out of me I've got nothing
left I've got nothing left shout me
you've got my mind setting I'm your wife
you better find something
wow that's hilarious yeah that's
hilarious
another person to eat
oh yeah it's juicy oh aroused
so
quickly because I'll be tired it's all
hype it's all hot
the next one I ate rice with a spoon
today
so I can experience life from the
perspective of someone driven by greed
and self-indulgence
foreign
that's hilarious ah this one's sweetened
me
um You probably saw this one it was on
Instagram
the UK government needs to introduce
podcast licenses it's getting out of
hands
is getting out of hand
I know we contribute to this but it is
getting out of hand
I'ma get I'm for it hey I'm for it but
boy yeah there's a couple podcasts now
there's a couple podcasts now there are
there are they're about all right last
one oh my God two year three girls
arguing in my lesson and one just said
shut up look at your edge control your
mum has shaky hands
wow that's dialects
in year three I wouldn't know where to
direct my anger
[Music]
wow I mean I grabbed her or my mom look
at your edge control your mum has
shaking I just Spam so sorry he didn't
touch me it's fine
that would rattle my world because I'd
be so vexed on my mum when I get back
home when she come through pick me up do
better when she comes to pick me up I
can see the up laughing in the
background looking at my mom's shaky
hands yeah that's a parking mom
and that's why we wrap up the episode
guys all right
your mom has shaky hands brother
that that oh that's a fish that's a fist
fight it has to be physically wow edge
control where you cannot work from
brother yeah three damn your mama's
shaky hands
no I couldn't tell them that I couldn't
tell my mom that that's how I got
insulted today
I couldn't tell my mom that of course
not all right guys guys that's our
that's our lesson for today yeah man
thank you very very much
um as always guys heading over to
patreon.com
to get those extra episodes and of
course grab your tickets to the SMG Log
Cabin tour make sure you do and um yeah
[Music]
foreign